24 consultó directamente al tribunal
supremo electoral este lunes 10 de julio
y sobre la oficialización de resultados
dicen que no lo planean hacer en las
próximas horas pero lo que sí se tiene
por certeza por seguro es que lo vayan a
hacer durante esta semana Luego por
supuesto de esta resolución de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia además hay que tener
en cuenta que fue el propio tribunal
supremo electoral quien hace dos días le
solicitó a la alta corte que rechazara
la solicitud la impugnación de esos
cuatro partidos políticos de querer
contar voto tras voto de hacer un conteo
físico de lo ocurrido en las elecciones
el 25 de junio y que entonces diera por
cumplido todo el proceso de las actas
que se realizó la semana pasada en ese
sentido lo más seguro es que el tribunal
supremo electoral entonces ratifique
tanto a sanda Torres como a Bernardo
Arévalo para la segunda vuelta electoral
programada para el 20 de julio con esta
resolución de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia Bernardo Arévalo se precipitó
estaba muy entusiasmado publicó un trino
en el que decía estamos oficialmente en
la segunda vuelta pero muy pronto lo
borró y enseguida publicó algo más cauto
y poético diciendo entonces que el
movimiento semilla Ahora tiene un camino
para germinar entre tanto la candidata
Sandra Torres no se pronunció al
respecto pero si unas horas antes
diciendo que había un gran temor de que
se robaran las elecciones en Guatemala
Andrés Pero explíquenos qué tan
sorprendente es la decisión de la corte
y si tiene algo que ver el mensaje que
publicó previamente el presidente de
Alejandro yamatei
no debería de ser sorprendente este
resultado o esta resolución de la corte
en un estado de derecho y más aún
teniendo en cuenta que las elecciones
del pasado 25 de junio aquí en Guatemala
se llevaron con transparencia según lo
dijeron los observadores Internacionales
la sociedad civil los fiscales de varios
de los partidos Y pues también el propio
tribunal supremo electoral pero la
historia reciente de Guatemala salpicada
con tantos actos de corrupción y de
impunidad podría abrir la puerta a
cualquier escenario sobre todo mirando
con lupa la Corte Suprema de Justicia
que desde hace más de ocho años tiene
los mismos magistrados que debieron
haber sido cambiados en el 2019 y que
varios de ellos dos en específico están
incluidos en la lista Engel como actores
que favorecen la corrupción y se le dice
que la corte puede llegar a ser un actor
corrupto aquí en Guatemala sin embargo
lo que dijo yamatei
de respetar esta segunda vuelta pues
coincide con lo de la Corte Suprema pero
no se puede conjeturar que El Ejecutivo
y el judicial estén en este momento
alineados